there's nothing like a good kung fu
movie is there but which films are
champions of the genre here's our list
of the best kung fu movies of all time
does one of your favorites make the cut
commonly praised as one of the best kung
fu movies of the 1990s iron monkey was
proof that even though its golden period
had ended the kung fu genre still had
some life in it based in part on chinese
folk hero wang fehung and his father's
encounter with the mysterious martial
artist known only as the iron monkey
it's a film that boasts some first-rate
action scenes full of lightning-fast
kicks and epic slow motion action donnie
yen stars as wang ka ying a chinese
physician and skilled martial artist
forced to battle the masked robin
hood-like vigilante called the iron
monkey after his son is kidnapped by a
corrupt city official when the iron
monkey proves his heroism by saving wang
kaying's son the two fighters set out to
combat the city's bureaucratic
politicians together originally released
in 1993 iron monkey was warmly received
by critics and moviegoers earning an
approval rating of 91 percent on rotten
tomatoes it was even listed number 99 on
empire magazine's the 100 best films of
world cinema list iron monkey would
later see an expanded release in the us
after quentin tarantino convinced
miramax to acquire the distribution
rights the beloved director kung fu
super fans stamp of approval broadened
its appeal even further
the tone style is immensely strong
and immune to nearly any weapon
when it's properly used it's almost
invincible
a kung fu film with the loyal cult
following five deadly venoms is a
classic product of the shaw brothers
studio the seeds of which launched in
1925 and would go on to become hong
kong's largest production company yang
taya is a young martial artist
instructed by his dying master to seek
out the other former students all of
whom have become powerful masters of a
specific fighting style and to eliminate
any who are using their abilities for
nefarious purposes these five students
fighting styles have each earned a
specific name the centipede the snake
the scorpion the lizard and the toad
they are all based on the five poisonous
creatures from chinese folklore and yang
tia was taught a little bit of each
combat style by today's standards five
deadly venoms may be seen as somewhat
cheesy and dated but it is exactly this
over stylization that makes it an
enjoyable essential kung fu romp and
mandatory viewing for any would-be fan
of the genre one of the most influential
kung fu movies ever made it's been
referenced in everything from kill bill
to tupac's five deadly venoms
additionally the movie's dialogue
appears in several wu-tang clan songs
like the mystery of chess boxing and
intro shaolin finger jab
[Applause]
after bruce lee's death in 1973 the kung
fu film entered a strange state of limbo
at its peak of popularity but suddenly
without its most prominent leading man
genre producers desperately scrambled
for potential stars to succeed lee few
actors matched his intensity gravitas
and on-screen presence instead they
turned to an actor who had the
physicality but wanted to take the genre
in a wholly unexpected direction that
actor was jackie chan when speaking to
the new york times in 1995 about his
early years in the business chan said i
wanted to be like a chaplain or buster
keaton but all the martial arts
directors i worked with wanted me to
copy bruce lee after making a name for
himself with the 1978 hong kong kung fu
comedy drunken master chan tried and
failed to break into hollywood he left
the american film industry dissatisfied
and disappointed in the quality of films
like battle creek brawl resolving to
make his own movie chan went to work
co-writing directing and starring in
police story the first in a series of
successful action crime movies in police
story chan plays a hong kong police
detective framed for the murder of
another officer by a powerful drug
kingpin blending slapstick comedy with
large-scale action sequences police
story was a massive blockbuster in
eastern markets when first released the
movie went on to win the 1986 hong kong
film award for best film matt zoller
sites of roger ebert.com praised the
movie's famous mall fight scene calling
it a masterpiece of choreography and one
of the greatest stunts in the history of
movies in 2016 it was ranked the fourth
best action film in a timeout poll which
consisted of critics filmmakers and
stunt actors
master of the flying guillotine is a
kung fu film within the usha genre a
martial arts movie blending elements of
fantasy and magical realism
traditionally set in ancient china and
while it may be lesser known than most
other kung fu films that came out around
the same time it remains an influential
and enjoyable movie a sequel to director
co-writer and star jimmy yang woo's
earlier one-armed boxer master of the
flying guillotine sees the previous
film's titular protagonist defending
himself from a vengeful blind assassin
wielding a deadly buzzsaw hat that
decapitates anyone who wears it named by
quentin tarantino is one of his favorite
films of all time it's easy to see his
attraction to the flick it's pure 70s
camp full of cartoonish violence and
flashy gloriously ridiculous fighting
moves as an example in one of the film's
most famous scenes jimmy wang's boxer
manages to punch the assassin through
the roof and into his own coffin since
its release master of the flying
guillotine has been praised by
publications like the new york times as
one of the best kung fu films it has
even been referred to as the quote holy
grail of hong kong martial arts movies
of the 70s by los angeles times kevin
thomas
in the 1990s the kung fu genre saw a
resurgence in popularity this was thanks
in large part to films starring donnie
yen and jet li who were among the most
charismatic and proficient martial
artists turned actors to come along
since bruce lee and jackie chan in the
film that rocketed lee to stardom the
actor would appear as the legendary folk
hero wang hung a physician as talented
in the medical field as he is in kung fu
lee's wong fehung trains a local militia
to combat a criminal martial arts
syndicate as well as encroaching western
colonizers praised by critics once upon
a time in china retains an 88 approval
rating on rotten tomatoes and was
nominated for best film at the 11th hong
kong film awards the movie is mostly
remembered today for its incredible
action scenes and for league using
everything from an umbrella to bamboo
sticks as lethal weapons but its story
about retaining one's cultural roots in
the face of rapid westernization makes
for a surprisingly political movie
hidden under the guise of a kung fu
flick
[Music]
another undisputed classic from shaw
brothers studio the 36th chamber of
shaolin is regarded by many fans of the
genre as one of the best kung fu films
ever made it jump-started the careers of
both its director lao karlion and its
star gordon liu in the eastern film
industry
lou plays a young student named lou yud
whose entire school is systematically
killed off by a brutal government regime
seeking vengeance the student travels to
a shaolin temple in order to learn kung
fu he is put to the test when he must
pass through the temple's 36 chambers
each emphasizing key combat and fighting
techniques to sharpen one's mind and
body a rare film where the training
scenes are as meticulously orchestrated
and fun to watch as the actual fight
sequences the 36th chamber of shaolin
was a milestone in the kung fu genre it
was proof that memorable kung fu films
could still emerge despite the drop-off
in popularity that post-bruce leaflix
suffered in the late 70s praised by
critics it has an audience approval
rating of 90 on rotten tomatoes and was
listed at number 22 in timeout's poll of
the 101 best action movies it was also a
direct influence on the wu-tang clan in
addition to referencing the film in the
name of their debut album enter the wu
tang 36 chambers wu-tang clan member
mast akilah took his name from one of
the film's alternate titles the master
killer
sequels rarely measure up to the success
and popularity of their predecessors
however the legend of drunken master not
only manages to match the strengths of
its original movie it surpasses it
entirely also known as legend master 2
the legend of drunken master is a major
improvement on the original drunken
master in every conceivable way the
sequel features better stunts better
action and better comedy released 16
years after the original drunken master
chan once again stars as folk hero wang
fehung a master of drinking and martial
arts both of which he combines to form
his unique drunken boxing fighting style
pressured by his father to give up
drinking and fighting for good wang
fehung must decide between obeying his
father's wishes and stopping a foreign
plot to steal priceless artifacts from
his homeland the legend of drunken
master earned near universal acclaim
including a number of prestigious awards
following its release
in 2015 the british film institute
included it on their 10 best action
movies list when discussing the final
showdown in his review of the film for
the chicago sun times roger ebert said
it may not be possible to film a better
fight scene
[Music]
kung fu films seldom win or earn
nominations from international film
festivals in 2000 however an usha film
broke through the mode delivering an
action-packed narrative with a
surprising amount of tender emotion
hidden beneath its violent surface
in crouching tiger hidden dragon hong
kong action star chao young fat plays
veteran warrior lee mubai who entrusts
his faithful 400 year old sword known as
the green destiny to his friend after he
decides to retire when a nimble young
thief steals the sword for herself
mubai's friend embarks on a journey to
recover it facing her own complex
feelings toward her old friend along the
way blending romance with kung fu
doesn't always make for a great combo
but in director anglie's very capable
hands a tender portrait of forbidden
love is delivered between rapid-fire
kicks and captivating sword fights
universally acclaimed upon release
crouching tiger hidden dragon won more
than 40 awards the film earned an oscar
nomination for best picture and won best
foreign language film best art direction
best original score and best
cinematography it's also far and away
the highest grossing foreign language
film ever released in the u.s
kung fu hustle is a modern kung fu film
more along the lines of a spoof than an
homage to the martial arts genre it was
director writer and star stephen chao's
follow-up to his hilarious hit shaolin
soccer a film that satirized the more
recent stunts found in martial arts
flicks of the early 2000s kung fu hustle
was designed as a parody of classic kung
fu movies featuring several retired
genre actors in prominent roles in the
film chao stars as sing an aspiring
low-level criminal trying to make a name
for himself as a legitimate bad guy by
joining the infamous axe gang when the
axe gang begins to wreak havoc on a
local slum called pig sty alley only to
find it populated by several kung fu
masters who have gone into hiding sing
must decide whether to join the gang or
save the neighborhood from certain
destruction while the fight scenes are
incredibly well done it's the movie's
comedic style that makes kung fu hustle
so enjoyable abandoning the laws of
physics completely characters are able
to move with cartoonish speed and
agility leading to a glowing review by
roger ebert in which he refers to it as
jackie chan and buster keaton meet
quentin tarantino and bugs bunny
praised by everyone from james gunn to
bill murray it may not have the most
hard-hitting action but it's definitely
the funniest kung fu movie you're likely
to find anywhere
the kung fu genre may have reached its
peak with bruce lee but more recent
movies have kept the genre alive for a
new generation to enjoy foremost among
these is eatman a fictionalized biopic
about the grand master of the martial
art wing chun who is known for training
some of the world's greatest martial
artists including bruce lee the first in
a five film series eep man stars donnie
yen as the legendary martial artist who
faces constant challenges from local
combat experts and professional soldiers
trying to prove themselves during the
sino-japanese war while the historical
accuracy of the film is debatable the
success it achieved is not earning a
positive reception from critics the
movie would go on to launch a popular
film franchise ignite yen's career and
earn heaps of awards in variety
magazine's review of flick derek ellie
wrote
jen who's taking on real star charisma
in middle age is aces eep with the
simple dignity that exactly mirrors the
movie zone and a gracefulness in combat
that's very different from his trademark
whiplash style on rotten tomatoes the
movie has an 86 approval rating with the
critical consensus stating at once
beholden to the established conventions
of the genre and delightfully subversive
of them eep man is one of the most
exciting and refreshingly character
driven martial arts films in years
a man who adores all things film when
quentin tarantino set out to create his
own martial arts movie in the early
2000s he blended all of his favorite
b-movie genres together into the massive
kung fu extravaganza that is kill bill
spanning two films and clocking in at a
total run time of four hours kill bill
stars uma thurman as a woman initially
known only as the bride she was left for
dead by her former top-notch mercenary
team led by her ex-lover bill waking
from the coma he and his gang put her in
thurman's bride embarks on a
globe-trotting mission to hunt down all
of her former teammates who wronged her
eventually coming face to face with bill
himself one of tarantino's classics the
ingenuity of kill bill lies in its
endless references to kung fu films near
and dear to his heart a lovingly made
homage to a movie genre he clearly holds
dear it was the subject of widespread
critical praise it earned several bafta
and golden globe nominations including
best actress and best supporting actor
[Music]
in many ways what clint eastwood or john
wayne was for the western bruce lee was
for martial arts movies but while
eastwood and wayne had decades and
dozens of films to establish their
legacies lee did it in a fraction of
that time enter the dragon shows lee as
a skilled martial artist sent undercover
to compete in a fighting tournament
organized by a dangerous international
criminal almost inarguably the most
influential kung fu movie of all time
enter the dragon is considered lee's
masterpiece it's also one of the most
financially successful films ever made
grossing over 400 times its estimated
budget of 850 000
at the time of its release enter the
dragon earned mixed to average reviews
though later critics would be far more
generous complimenting the movie's
action music and lee's performance the
new york times howard thompson wrote of
the film the picture is expertly made
and well meshed it moves like lightning
and brims with color it is also the most
savagely murderous and numbing hand
hacker not a gun in it you will ever see
anywhere the enduring influence of enter
the dragon can be found not only in
nearly every kung fu film that has
followed since but in modern video game
series manga and anime as well the plot
of the film resembles the basic premise
of mortal kombat and the movie has been
cited as a key influence on the dragon
ball franchise
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]